- Hi my name's Nick and I know the first
two words of the Canadian Nation Anthem.
Americans Try to Sing "O Canada"
- I'm excited to sing the
Canadian National Anthem.
I know a *beep* about it.
- My grandma's from Thunder Bay, Ontario
and she sings it all the time.
So I feel like I know the very beginning
really, really well and then...
- I'm pretty sure I know all the words
because I learned the song in Junior High
because I was that kid.
- But I've sung the
Canadian National Anthem
plenty of times.
- I lived in Canada for
four years. I'm American.
I'm pretty sure I never learned O Canada.
- ♫ O CANADA ♫
- ♫ OUR HOME AND NATIVE LAND! ♫
♫ TRUE PATRIOT LOVE ♫
♫ IN ALL THY SONS COMMAND ♫
- True patriot love in
all thy sons command.
I don't think you should
command anyone to love you.
- Sons and daughters...
- ♫ WITH GLOWING HEARTS
WE SEE THEE RISE, ♫
- I never really got why
your hearts would glow.
That seems like an E.T. related issue.
♫ THE TRUE NORTH STRONG AND FREE ♫
I love that they delineate
themselves as the true north.
It's like North American sure,
but the northern part, Canada,
that's worth celebrating.
- It sounds like Game of Thrones.
- ♫ FROM FAR AND WIDE, O CANADA,
WE STAND ON GUARD FOR THEE♫
- I knew it was something like
far and wide and about the...
I thought there was
something about the plains,
but I couldn't even understand them.
- They mean that because Canada only lives
on the far and the wide.
There's nothing in the center.
♫ GOD KEEP OUR LAND ♫
♫ GLORIOUS AND FREE! ♫
♫ O CANADA, WE STAND ON GUARD FOR THEE. ♫
Play hockey!
- I think you guys might
actually have it wrong.
- Really the Canadian Nation
Anthem is blame Canada.
Like come on, Salsbury wrote
it and that's what it is now.
- Maple syrup, I don't know.
- Oh my God! I knew none of these.
- I think I nailed it.
- Designed from like Christmas carol?
- I'm really in so much trouble.
- I knew O CANADA which is
more than I know for probably
any other national anthem.
- It sounds like a regular
old national anthem.
Lots of God and stuff
in there so that's good.
- This country's great!
We all love it!
Hey guess what Canada, we're
gonna protect you all the time
because we love you,
you're the True North.
You're really really cold
and most people don't want to inhabit you,
but we will protect you
from those urchins that do.